[Music]
what's the matter honey I ran out of
flowers I'm sorry
from flower girl to the bride Ashley
Olsen's reportedly a married woman it's
so exciting Paige Dix reports the Full
House star tied the knot with her
longtime Beau Louis Eisner in a secret
wedding ceremony at a Bel Air home last
week the outlet notes there were only a
few dozen guests there and we can only
assume one being her twin sister Mary
Kate I mean we're kind of just like
connected
we know each other's thinking all the
time pretty much we always kind of know
what we want but if we're stuck in a
situation or we need um you know a
justification or
or something like that we turn to each
other specific details about the event
are still under wraps but an Insider
tells page six that it went late with 50
people or so total Howie will you marry
me why
so we could eat wedding cake is it
chocolate cake who cares it's this big
and it got Frosty so who's Ashley's
lucky groom well Louie is an artist born
to Lisa Eisner a jewelry designer and
Eric Eisner an attorney who was once the
president of the David Gaffin company
Ashley's been dating Louise since 2017
in 2019 the pair sparked engagement
rumors but never confirmed anything
officially they're very private and are
rarely seen out together but Louis did
share this photo of Ashley last year on
Instagram taking a hike together they
also made their red carpet debut in
September for Louie's father's
non-profit event we've stayed really
normal and down to earth I think and
haven't let the success thing go to our
head and
I guess we've had we've gone to school
we've led a normal life basically and
now Ashley's celebrating this big life
moment congrats to the newlyweds
[Music]